move on to washington and the fallout
from the failure of the senate and
democrats there to push through
legislation to protect abortion rights
nationwide female house democrats staged
a protest to show their disapproval of
the senate vote yesterday as the nation
waits for a landmark ruling on the issue
from the supreme court scott mcfarland
is outside the high court for us once
again this morning scott good morning
tony good morning to you congress took a
largely symbolic vote on this measure to
codify roe vs wade and as expected it
failed raising the stakes higher for
this ruling from the high court
no twists no turns it went nearly
straight down party lines
the motion is not agreed to
the senate blocked debate on a measure
writing some federal abortion rights
into law with all republicans their
extreme proposal goes way
way beyond codifying the status quo
and west virginia democrat joe manchin
opposing we should not be dividing this
country further than we're already
divided vice president kamala harris
presided over the vote and this vote
clearly suggests that the senate
is not where the majority of americans
are on this issue
inside house democrats crossed the
capitol chanting
and outside
so what do you do next
well next we just start campaigning like
crazy i think it needs to be
a drum beat illinois governor j.p
pritzker says democrats in his own party
are not sounding the alarm loud enough
leading into the midterm elections his
state of illinois is now surrounded by
five states that are said to restrict or
completely end access to abortion if roe
versus wade is struck down by the high
court as anticipated we need to be
talking about this making sure that
voters know about this from now through
november and frankly as long as it takes
as crowds continue to gather near some
of the justice's homes state and local
law enforcement agencies are issuing
awareness reports that demonstrations
may become flash points for violence
with little to no warning
outside the homes of the supreme court
justices there's been at requests for
added protection from the governors of
virginia and maryland meantime saturday
abortion rights groups rally at the
washington monument across from the
white house as they try to continue to
have their voices heard
nate
we know this will continue to be the
topic of conversation scott thank you